[Music]
it's time for film theory these YouTube
delights will have me mesh ends
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the amusement park for your mind sure we
don't have any roller coasters or cotton
candy or Ferris wheels but we do have
science math and history lessons wait
where are you going come back Mack but
fine I know what you all really wants
excessive violence and gratuitous nudity
have my rights right and when it comes
to blood and boobs no one beats HBO
penny who doesn't love Game of Thrones
and huh Game of Thrones and well those
crafty HBO executives knew exactly how
to solve their programming woes make a
show with even more nudity and more gore
than Game of Thrones that's right today
i'm talking about Westworld the show for
everyone who ever went to Disney World
and thought to themselves you know what
this would be so much more magical if I
could just shoot Mickey and then get it
on with a cast of it's a small world by
the way in case you haven't noticed yet
this episode might get a little NSFW now
for those of you who are unfamiliar
Westworld takes place in the
not-too-distant future where mankind is
on the brink of a new technological
revolution machines that not only pass
the Turing test who can behave think and
act like actual human beings so
obviously we stuff him into a Wild West
Show where rich people can kill and have
sex with them I mean I can't think of
any other practical use for such
advanced AI robotic technology than put
them into an x-rated Six Flags
nope can't think of one single better
use for a robot than a Wild West themed
amusement park
nailed it fictional television future
anyway besides all the blood squibs and
boobs there's one thing that keeps
people tuning into Westworld the show
week after week and that is the mystery
there are so many different mysteries
it's honestly hard to keep track of them
all who's the man in black what's at the
center of the maze who's Arnold and
that's just naming three yet West world
over the course of its fantastic first
10 episodes answered every single one
suck on that lost and I really wanted to
do an episode covering some of these
issues as the show was running because
one I really wanted to talk about it and
two I really wanted to introduce you
guys to a show that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but I couldn't
because when a typical episode of film
theory takes two weeks or more to make
it makes it really hard to come up with
videos that didn't get answered in the
following weeks episode but now with the
season done and people slowly catching
up on everything that they missed
there's one mystery still left standing
one mystery that Westworld hasn't
revealed yet and that's the location of
the West world Park and this isn't just
some random piece of trivia it's an
important question for the show in fact
in an interview right before the season
finale co-creator Jonathan Nolan offered
up this cryptic tease on the parks
location quote by the end of the first
season if you're paying close attention
you will know where the park is and
quote he was then immediately
interrupted by his co-creator and wife
Lisa joy who disagreed but of course
this spurred on every single over
analyzer online to theorize on just
where the park was set gonna be on its
own private island or perhaps mainland
Australia or Mars or an asteroid in
space well let me tell you after
carefully going through each episode of
Westworld and its online marketing none
of those theories actually hold water
nope today I'm trolling through
televisions most cryptic show to solve
the last lingering question from its
first season where is West world the
answer will be revealed by the end of
today's episode but if you want to hints
well you've already got this
let's start by dunking the most common
theories first an island sure Westworld
may be based on a film and book by
Michael Crichton who yes definitely had
a thing for islands but if west world
was set on an island or any body of land
on earth you would naturally expect some
sort of indigenous livestock bugs birds
anything really but per the West world
terms and conditions website only the
flies that you find within the park are
actually real per the website quote a
livestock within the del o sparks our
hosts that's West world terminology for
the robots with the notable exception of
flies end quote
thus all islands on the surface of Earth
are automatically ruled out of
consideration so then what about Mars or
space well I've looked at all the
Internet's best evidence and it all
stems from a single shot in the deepest
bowels of the West world headquarters
where a globe is visible for just a
split second this globe according to one
person online looks suspiciously like it
has continents of Mars and not of Earth
however the way that the light plays on
the image it's just clearly a globe of
Earth that was misread you can even make
out the light underside of South America
on it so that theory feels a bit dead in
the water as well but what if West world
was in the one place that you would
never think to look one right under our
noses and under the sea oh now this is
my favorite part because it's time to
gather some evidence someone left some
evidence point number one sighs if we
know nothing else about West's world we
know that it's really big really really
big in an interview with Jonathan Nolan
he estimated that West's world is
roughly five hundred square miles for
comparison Disney World is only 40
square miles and that's the biggest
amusement park in the world at five
hundred square miles New York City would
be half of West World Park so getting
your hands on land almost twice the size
of NYC
is gonna s uck but the ocean covers 141
million 600,000 square miles let me
repeat that
a hundred and forty-one million square
miles more than enough room for a
sprawling
version of Freddy's pizzeria point
number two the weather within West world
never changes it's always the same calm
static western hue again per the West
world Terms & Conditions site quote
statistically speaking you're more
likely to die from a lightning strike
than to die while in Adele OHS park and
quotes but if that's true which
obviously it must be since it's online
and everything online must be true
within the desert must have a very non
desert like temperature considering a
typical desert in the summer sun can
reach highs of 140 degrees Fahrenheit
before plummeting below 50 at nights and
that level of fluctuation can and does
kill so if the Telos corporation claims
that west world is basically the safest
place on earth that means that they have
complete control over the weather it
can't actually be a real desert but if
it's not then what exactly is it well in
another interview with Jonathan Nolan he
revealed one of the biggest influences
on West world the video game BioShock
quote I was a big fan of the Bioshock
video games which I thought were among
the most literate and thoughtful pieces
of entertainment that I've seen in the
last 10 years end quotes
him and me both and in BioShock we
follow our protagonist Jack as he
navigates an art-deco Wonderland built
entirely you guessed it under water
contained in biospheres created by the
mysterious business tycoon Andrew Ryan
um sound a bit familiar Westworld even
has a super subtle reference to Bioshock
in the background of the third episode
in Robert Ford's workshop there's an
eerily familiar head in the background
the head of one of bioshock's most
famous characters sander Cohen and no
I'm not just hallucinating or seeing
things this was actually confirmed by
the creators these references could hint
at West's world being in an artificial
underwater biosphere which makes a ton
of sense in a biosphere West world
employees would have complete control
over the desert environment and could
absolutely guarantee complete safety
just look at the shape of the West
world's Park hologram an almost perfect
circle just like a biosphere this
underwater setting would also work
perfectly with West world's complete
isolation from the outside world
throughout the series the only events we
see are contained either in the park
itself or in the hallways of
the company headquarters the brief
glimpses of the outside world come in
via an unreliable Skype function sorry
it took me a while to get back to you
you know how hard it is getting an open
line out here given the technical
marvels of the near future
I mean they've crafted sentient robots
for crying out loud it's odd that
something as simple as Skype would be so
unreliable but wireless communication
has always been dependent on radio
signals traveling from a transmitter to
a receiver these signals those start to
break down when they have to move
through electrical conductors electrical
conductors like you guessed it ocean
water if Westworld is under the ocean it
makes perfect sense that communication
would be so spotty but what about the
satellites I hear you saying and I knew
I'd have to contend with some really
smart fellow theorists while talking
about the show since man you guys solved
so many of these shows mysteries early
some people solved like the biggest
mysteries of the show within the first
two episodes it was wild and yes we do
hear about different satellites flying
around the park early on in Westworld
Bernard and Elsie discovered that a
rogue Android has smuggled a satellite
uplink in its arm
and on the employees screens we even see
options for a satellite view
now obviously satellites are typically
found in space yet many of these
satellites could be disrupted and as
such the Department of Defense recently
set up satellites in a place far more
secure hundreds of feet under the ocean
no joke this is a real life and not just
the universe of Westworld it's called
the tactical undersea network
architectures program or tuna I see what
you did there DARPA so tuna uses optical
fiber based tech to quote integrate a
military tactical data network into an
undersea Network and quote the fact that
the Delos corporation in Westworld has
to resort to smuggling data outside the
park suggests that they don't have
access to more traditional satellite
uploading tech but rather a much harder
to crack undersea satellite network but
the biggest clue that Westworld is set
under the sea the one that convinced me
that this theory is correct
lies in the fine print throughout the
course of this episode we visited the
west-world web site a couple times the
whole page dedicated to the terms and
conditions of going to the park well
these terms and conditions are filled
with really specific and really weird
word choices the entry of the park is
our
- as the port of entry quote upon
entering the del Oeste nations port of
entry you are agreeing to the terms and
conditions as laid out in this documents
later on in the contract the area
outside the park is called the mainland
road again if Delos Inc or any Delos
entity believes in its sole discretion
that a violation of these terms has
occurred it may take any and all
corrective action it deems appropriate
without notice including contacting
local authorities on the mainland and
the quote and finally after guests have
left the park they have to stay at a
decompression chamber final quote
Westworld is an experience like no other
and we've designed the world's finest
decompression chamber the Mesa gold
end quote all of these words port
mainland decompression chamber are all
nautical or sea related terms sure maybe
one would be a coincidence but three
terms directly referencing the ocean
that's way too big to ignore so I did
some further digging into the terms and
conditions website poring over each
section and that it finally hit me in
the section on crime the page specifies
that all crimes within Westworld will
first be investigated by the owning
Delos corporation and that quote they've
successfully avoided outside court
entities for their entire existence
end quote it's basically saying Dell
owes a business corporation has absolute
judicial power within its borders it
would be as if Walt Disney could try any
crime that happened at Epcot which means
that the park is treated as practically
its own sovereign nation for all legal
purposes now any sort of land-based park
would be subject to the laws wherever
they're located but out in the sea
things start to get murkier occur the
United Nations Convention on the law of
the sea article 87 1 states that the
high seas are open to all states whether
coastal or landlocked
the same article reveals that within the
sea you have the freedom to construct
artificial islands as long as it doesn't
interfere with trade routes just like a
biosphere underwater thus it's only
under maritime law that the Delos
corporation would have complete judicial
control over its park just as the terms
and conditions website states but if
you're still still not convinced let's
just jump back to that scene with the
globe in episode one there's one really
simple detail here
a lot of people have missed it's the
simplest solution missed how come is
Raisa the Occam's razor of this
situation is the water pouring in from
the walls where's it coming from if we
go by the Delos corporate map the final
level is barely at the base of Castle
Rock barely at ground level so then why
is there so much water cascading around
their feet when we're underground the
only solution that makes any sort of
sense that fits all of the conditions
the size isolation legality and leaking
water is if West world's actually
surrounded by water on all sides deep
within the ocean itself literally 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea now doesn't that
make the wait for season 2 even cooler
not just samurai world but underwater
samurai world I told you all you'd like
the show but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and guts
welcome back to the super amazing end
card tournament back by popular demand
but now we have to do it a little bit
differently since YouTube is getting rid
of annotations so Westworld
have you seen the show before this
episode have I convinced you to go watch
it
or do you still not care cooking one of
the options and let me know this is
honestly also me testing out a new way
of doing the super amazing end card
tournament because that a-hole
annotation thing this is the new way to
do polls here so hey help me out test it
out I'm excited to see how it works
hey if you want more mind-blowing
coverage on west world then lasso the
button that just appeared on screen to
check out a fascinating look into the
philosophy of West world after watching
this video you see on screen I went and
rewatched the series and oh my gosh I
got so much more out of it now if you'll
excuse me I need to go give myself a
dose of I bleach that opening moment oh
boy I may have crossed the line on that
one